- Salut Romain, ha qu'est ce que tu manges ?
- De la concoyotte !
- Ha, c'est marrant alors cet aspect et cette odeur là ça me rappelle un peu tu sais...
- Nooon, je veux rien savoir !
Le corps humain est une machine merveilleuse, une mécanique de précision
fascinante de complexité, un assemblage de pièces d'horlogerie qui fonctionnent à l'unisson grâce à des organes et des fluides ébaubissants de
sophistication mais il est aussi capable de produire des matières auxquelles on aimerait ne jamais avoir à faire
Est ce que ça vous est déjà arrivé d'avoir comme une sorte de gêne dans le fond de la gorge
un goût assez désagréable dans la bouche puis de tousser et de cracher une petite boule de pâte blanchâtre voir un peu jaunâtre... non ?
enfin si c'est le cas vous n'avez sûrement pas pu vous empêcher de la tripoter et vous avez constaté qu'elles se
désagréger entre vos doigts en laissant dessus une odeur
absolument dégueulasses. Ces petites boules qui sont pas forcément si petites que ça d'ailleurs
ce sont des tonsillolithes comme on dit dans le jargon
littéralement des pierres d'amygdales elles se forment dans des cavités que certains d'entre nous au niveau des amygdales et qu'on appelle des cryptes
C'est un mélange de cellules mortes, de bactéries et de résidus alimentaires qui vont se loger dans ces cavités qui macèrent
qui fermentent et qui forment cette pâte qui donne extrêmement mauvaise haleine qu'on appelle du caseum, en latin ça veut dire fromage
le fromage c'est comme on veut quand on
Allez on change d'étage, si je vous dis smegma, vous me dites ?
Hé non, perdu c'est pas un médicament contre la diarrhée mais c'est pas beaucoup plus appétissant le smegma c'est cette substance
blanchâtre, pâteuse et souvent mal odorante qu'on retrouve volontiers dans les plis de nos parties génitales et qu'on appelle communément du fromage de ****
Salakis, au bon lait de p****
et pourtant les femmes produisent aussi du smegma comme les hommes grâce à des petites glandes prévues à cet effet
et oui parce que le smegma c'est pas juste là pour vous mettre mal à l'aise pendant un premier date, ça sert à quelque
chose. C'est un composant de la fonction auto nettoyante de notre petit matériel intime
d'ailleurs en latin et en grec smegma ça veut dire savon, détergent,
nettoyage c'est un mélange de la fameuse substance sécrétée par nos petites glandes et de cellules mortes
il joue aussi un rôle de lubrification et même si on n'a pas encore tout bien compris il pourrait participer à l' équilibre de la
flore génitale ça pourrait même être une sorte de signature odorante personnelle
smegma numéro 5
de celle de diallo
pas de panique il suffit de nettoyer ça au savon doux et à l'eau une fois par jour et tout se passe bien
Bon on descend encore d'un étage mais on reste dans l'industrie fromagère avec le grunge
la légende veut que ce terme désigne non seulement un style musical
Mais aussi la crème qui se niche entre des orteils sales
bon apparemment il ya que les français qui appelle ça comme ça par contre en néerlandais ont dit "Teninkas"
littéralement fromage d'orteils
"Les produits laitiers sont nos amis pour la vie!"
Peu importe comment ça s'appelle mais qu'est ce que c'est que cette matière ?
C'est un mélange de transpiration et de peaux mortes qui ont passé un certain temps enfermés dans des chaussettes et des chaussures bien
macérées et qu'on finit par être colonisées par des bactéries qu'il y trouve tout ce dont elles ont besoin pour vivre et qui sont
responsables de l'odeur parmi ces bactéries on retrouve des staphylocoques, des microcoxus et même des
brévine bacterium qui sont de la même famille que celle utilisée pour la fabrication de certains fromages
comme le maroille, le munster ou la raclette
Vous en avez tous déjà produit quelques cuillerées et que ce soit dans des boutons dans des plaies autour des yeux ou dans un abcès
Le pus c'est un liquide guerrier dans la majorité des cas c'est le résultat du combat de votre organisme
contre une infection il est composé de débris de cellules des globules blancs qui luttent contre les germes et de ces germes eux - même des
bactéries mortes ou vivantes mais le pus n'est pas qu'une brute
il a aussi sa fibre artistique et il offre une large gamme de couleurs et d'odeurs
- ça sent la noisette !
- tout ça dépend directement du germe en cause dans l'infection ça va du blanc crème en passant par le jaune le
vert le gris le brun sans parler du sympathique bacille pyocyanique qui propose quant à lui un pus d'une jolie couleur bleutée
Pour s'en débarrasser il faut un
évacuer la matière
Deux identifier le germe en cause pour proposer un antibiotique efficace mais tout ça c'est le médecin qui s'en charge
faites pas les malins fun fact il existe aussi du pus sans germes qu'on appelle du pus aseptique bon c'est dans certains cas particulier
du pus propre
"C'est chelou ..."
Bon allez avant de partir parce que je pense aussi aux intolérants au lactose
vous prendrez bien une petite tartine de tapenade parmi les matières produites par votre corps auxquelles vous n'avez probablement pas du tout envie d'être confronté
vomissements fécaloides oui vomissements comme vomir fécaloides comme ...
Comme ça et alors attention avoir des vomissements fécaloides ça ne veut pas dire vomir du caca au sens strict
soyons précis disons que les vomissements prennent l'aspect et l'odeur des matières fécales
bon déjà rien que ça c'est pas très convivial, en réalité c'est plutôt du liquide,
des sécrétions intestinales
chargées de toute la petite armée de bactéries fécales
qui remontent, se mélangent au contenu de l'estomac avant de ressortir par le haut
et si ça sort par en haut c'est parce que s'est bouché par en bas
ça peut aussi mais c'est rarissime être le signe d'une fistule
gastro colique
oui alors une fistule c'est une espèce de canal qui se crée entre deux organes qui devrait pas communiquer entre eux normalement donc là en
l'occurrence une fistule gastro colique, c'est une fistule entre l'estomac et le gros intestin
Bon, dans tous les cas vous vous en doutez c'est grave hein donc la solution
c'est la chirurgie voilà dtc c'est fini pour aujourd'hui on se retrouve très vite pour une nouvelle vidéo en attendant
continuer d'aimer votre corps et celui des autres avec ses qualités ses petits défauts
mais qu'est ce que je vais dire déjà et bon appétit bien sûr ah oui et surtout portez vous bien